[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه احنا نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز
المستجدات وفي العناوين
استهدف نقطه تفتيش للشرطه امام مطار
العسكريين وسط كابل
رئيس البرلماني الايراني
في الوقت المناسب
اوكرانيا تقول ان روسيا سنه 70 هجوما
براجمات الصواريخ ودفاعاتها تسقط 13 مسيره
روسيه
زعيم كوريا
النوويه هو رئيس الجاره الجنوبيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من افغانستان
حيث اشارت تقارير الى سقوط
ثمانيه في انفجار قرب المطار العسكري في
العاصمه كابول داخليه
في الانفجار الذي وقع في اطراف المطار
العسكري في الساعه الاولى من صباح اليوم
كما افاد مراسل العربيه انا الانفجار
استهدف تفتيشن التابعه للشرطه فيما تحدث
وسائل الاعلام
كبير بالقرب من وزاره الداخليه على طريق
كابول
مشاهدينا ينتمون الى المراسله العربيه عبد
الله نادر اهلا بك عبد الله وتفاصيل اوفى
عن هذا الهجوم
نعم فقد استهدف انفجار صباح اليوم اااا
نقطه التفتيشن قرب المطار الدولي في
العاصمه كابول
وبحسب السلطات الافغانيه في كابول فان هذا
الانفجار اسفر عن مقتل عدد من المتواجدين
هناك بحسب عبد النافع تكون المتحدث باسم
الداخليه الافغانيه ولم يفصل همم هل هؤلاء
الضحايا من المواطنين او من الجنود
الافغان واا كذلك اكد همم المتحدث باسم
همم قياده شرطه الافغانيه خالد الزدران
هذا الانفجار وهمم اكد كذلك ان الانفجار
همم ادى الى مقتل واصابه عدد من
المتواجدين في المنطقه ولم يحدد عدد
القتلى ولا عدد المصابين فيما طوقت الشرطه
الامنيه وهذه المنطقه ولا تسمح لاحد
بالاقتراب منها هذه المنطقه همم تعتبر
منطقه حساسه عسكريه
همم
مطار كابو الدولي يعتبر البوابه الوحيده
همم للبلد للخارج فيما تكون هذه البوابه
مكتظه وهذه المنطقه بالمواطنين مع
المدنيين فيما تفيد تقارير بان الانفجار
اسفل عن مقتل 10 واصابه ثمانيه اخرين ولن
تكون هذه الحصيله النهائيه في ما همم من
الممكن ان ترتفع هذه الحصيله همم
المصابين نعم هذا الانفجار ياتي ايضا ضمن
سلسلته هجمات طالت مناطقه مختلفه في
افغانستان خاصه منذ بدايه سيطره الطالبان
على الحكم هل تشير اصابع الاتهام حسب
المعلومات الاوليه الى جهه بعينها
لحد الان السلطات الافغانيه في كابول لم
توجه اصابع الاتهام الى ايه جهه ولم تتبنى
اي اتجهه مسؤوليه هذه
العمليه فيما تبنى داعش مسؤوليه العمليه
الدمويه التي نفذها شمال البلاد في
بداخشان وفي تخارق قبل ايام وتشير ملابسات
وحيثيات هذا الانفجار بان داعش ربما نفذ
هذه العمليه ليرسل رساله واضحه الى
السلطات في كابول بان العام الجديد الذي
بدا اليوم سيكون حافلا بمثل هذه العمليات
الدمويه التي ربما سيسحب وسيصحب معها همم
العنف المضاد من طرف طالبان بان طالبان
كذلك تهاجم معاقل
واماكن لعناصر داعش في في العاصمه التكامل
وفي بقيه المقاطعه التي تكثر فيها حركاته
وعناصر داعش وبالتالي الجهه الوحيده التي
تنفذ مثل هذه العمليات ضد الحكومه الحاليه
هي داعش اذا ال- ال- الهشاشه الامنيه ربما
بعد الثمه بارزه في كابول في مناطق مختلفه
في افغانستان منذ سيطره طالبا لكن هل هناك
من اجراءات احترازيه معينه او تدابير بدات
تتخدها حركه طالبان الحد من هذه
الانفجارات وكمح جناحيها
كل الطرق المؤديه الى العاصمه كابول والى
المدن الكبرى همم في افغانستان تخضع
لجراءات امنيه مكثفه وشديده جدا ولكن لحد
الان همم طالبا وقوته وقواتها الامنيه
والاجهزه الامنيه الثلاثه اخفقت همم في
التكهاني همم بهذه العمليات فضلا عن منعها
وعدم وقوعها فقد حدثت هناك عمليه دمويه
ادى الى مقتل قائد قائد ميداني همم في
طالبان في مدغشقان وحدث كذلك عمليه اخرى
تبنى داعش مسؤوليتها في مقاطعه همم تخار
الشماليه في مدينه التاء استهدف منطقه
مبتظه بالمواطنين ادى الى مقتل واصابه عدد
من المواطنين في العمر بشكل عام من طالبان
لحد الان لم تستطع ان تمنع وتتككهن بهذا
بمثل هذه العمليات
الشارع الافغاني في 30 ثانيه عبد الله كيف
ينظر الى هذه الاوضاع خاصه لما يتعلق
بتدخل الامريكي
المواطن الافغاني مغلوب على امره ومثل هذه
التي يؤدي الى الى بث الخوف والذعر في
الاوساط الافغانيه اذا انتشر الامن
والاستقرار النسبي في هذه المناطق فاذا ما
حدثت مثل هذه العمليات فان المواطن
الافغاني سوف يشعر بالخوف والذعر وعدم
الاستقرار وخاصه في هذه الايام الاخيره
شهد
المواطن الافغانيه عمليات دمويه شمال
البلاد وفي العاصمه كابل كما كانت هناك
عمليات دمويه في الجوامع وفي المساجد ادى
الى مقتل عدد من المواطنين والمدنيين
وبالتالي مثل هذه العمليه يؤدي الى زعزعه
الامن اذا كان همم المنفذ مثل هذه
الانفجارات يستطيع ان يستهدف او يوجه
ضربات الى مثل هذه الاماكن الحساسه
والخاضعه لنقاط التفتيش انه امنيه مكثفه
فانه يستطيع ان ينفذها في باقي المناطق
التي لم تخضعين معك على اي تطورات جديده
حول هذا الملف شكرا لك من كابل كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه
افغانيه ايضا مشاهدينا مصدقا الاكاديمي
الافغاني اسماعيل مشعل شهاداته احتجاجا
على حضر تعليم النساء في افغانستان متعه
عاهدا بمحاربه نظام طالبان حتى لو كلفه
الامر حياته وذلك وفق تصريحاته التي تم
بثها على احدى القنوات الاخباريه الخاصه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وخلال مقابله
مع وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه قالوا حضر
المتخصص فيما جهل الصحافه منذ اكثر من عقد
قال انه يرفع صوته ويقف الى جانب اخواته
متعه عددا بمواسطه الاحتجاج
[موسيقى]
يا نهار ابيض
كرتون كرتون نتورك
[موسيقى]
مع بدايه العام 2023 دخلت الاحتجاجات في
ايران يومها السابع بعد المئه من دون اي
اشاره الى نجاح محاولات السلطه القمعها
حيث شاهدت مدن ومناطق مختلفه احتجاجات
واسعه شله الحركه في الاسواق والشوارع
نشاطون ايرانيون افهدوا بان بازار طهران
شهد اضطرابات من قبل اضرابات من التجار
الذين اغلقوا محلهم تمديدا بالاوضاع
الاقتصاديه المترديه فيما تردد محتجون
شعارات ممدده من النظام وسط اجراءات امنيه
مشدده ودعوات لتظاهر عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي هذا ونشر حسابه 1,000 و500 نشر
مقطع فيديو يظهر حالته حاله عن في السوق
وصدى ترديد البطاقه هتافات منها الموت
دكتاتور وهذا عام تم في اثناء شهيده مدن
ايراني ده مختلفه منها جون رود وسندج
وساميرها ومشهد مظاهرات واسعه في الشوارع
ضد النظام كما افاد التقاير الاعلاميه
بسقوط قاتل على الاقل
استخدام قوات الامن الدخ الحيه واطلاق
الغاز المسيد للدموع ردا على المتطهرين
الذين رددوا شعارات منها الموت النظام
وهذا العام سيقتل حرس ايران الثوري هذا
واقر رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر
قالب بارتكابي اخطاء في اداره البلاد وداع
لاصلاح اليه الحكم وقال قال قال باب ان
تحديث نظام الحكم في جميع المجالات امر
ضروري كما شدد على اهميه حل مشاكل الشعب
واستخاذ القرار في الوقت المناسب وتحسين
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والمعيشه الايرانيين
وذلك في ظل تراجع القدره الشرعيه وانهيار
العمله
كم انتقدوا ممثل للمرشد الايراني في الحرس
الثوري غلام حسين غيبور مع سماه صمتا
المقربين من نظام في وجه الاحتجاجات
المتواصله في انحاء ايران وقال غيبورا في
تصريحات لوكاله اسنان الحكوميه ان بلاده
تتعرض لحرب مركبه خلال احتجاجات الاخيره
واصفا اياها بانها لا تقل اهميه عن محاربه
داعش ومن جهته اصدر حوض الثوري بيانا قدر
فيه بالاتهامات القيادي تجاه جنرالات
ومسؤولين من الدرجه الاولى بالوقوف بوجه
المرشد علي خامنه
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا من دبي انضم الى الباحث في الشهر
الايراني مسعود الفك اهلا بك سيد مسعود
معنا في هذه النشره كما تابعنا اذا
تصريحات رئيس البرلمان الايراني عندما
تحدث او طالب بضروره مراجعه نظام الحكم في
البلاد هل
يعد ذلك الصحوه الضمير من النظام الايراني
ام مناوره سياسيه ربما كلها ما بعدها على
خلفيه هذه الاحتجاجات
تحياتي لك والمشاهدين وكل عام وانتم بخير
[موسيقى]
لا يخرج عن اطار همم نظره النظام للامور
همم هناك همم نقطه مهمه في كلام قالبها
فيقول تحديث النظام وفقا لتعليمات المرشد
ووفقا لاراء المرشد المؤسس الخميني اي
النظام سوف يبقى في نفس الاطار همم لا
يمكن ان تحدث اي تغيرات هل هناك تغيير في
افكار المرشد المؤسس هذا النظام بني على
اساس افكار المنشد المؤسس وفقا للكتاب
الذي اصدره المرشد المؤسس قبل الثوره واسم
الكتاب الحكومه الاسلاميه وهناك الحكومه
الاسلاميه في وجهه نظر المرشد المؤسس هي
حكم الولي الفقيه همم الذي الان يحكم فيه
ايران لذا اتوقع حديث قلبظ سوف يؤدي الى
تغيير جذري في هذا النظام او تركيبه
النظام الا انه ركز بان التحديث يخص
الشؤون الاقتصاديه
وبهذه الطريقه عجله الوضع الاقتصادي السيء
عن الوضع السياسي الشيئ الذي ادى الى هذا
الوطن الاقتصادي لذا دون اي تحديث سياسي
لا يمكن احداث تغيير اقتصادي في داخل يعني
هو حصل الامر في مساله الازمه الاقتصاديه
لكن بنظر ايضا الى تصريحات اخرى متزامنه
وهي تصريحات وفي المرشده خائنه عفوا الذي
انتقد فيها مسؤولينها في داخل النظام مثل
هذه التصريحات يعني هل تشيبي اتساع دائره
همم الخلافات والتباينات داخل هذه
المنظومه
هي اكثر من ما تكون خلافات في داخل
المنظومه في واقع الامر توقعات من اكثر
الجهات تشددا من الجهات الاخرى ان تكون
بنفس المستوى من التشدد لذا عندما يتحدث
هذا المسؤول في الحرس الثوري يتحدث عن
الذين لم يكونوا بالدرجه القصوى من التشدد
تجاه الاحتجاجات واعتبر هذا التصرف هو
بمثابه الوقوف بوجه المرشد لان المرشد هو
الذي استخدم هذا الكلام الذي هو يتحدث عنه
ال- ال- الخواص كما سماهم المرشد لاول مره
هنا طلب المرشد من جميع المسؤولين ان
يكونوا واضحين ولهم مواقف واضحه
وشديده اتجاه الاحتجاجات والان يكررها هذا
المسؤول في الحرس الدوري المساله تتلخص في
مواجهه الاح وفي مواجهه المحتجين دون ان
وهذا اكبر اشاره بان النظام الايراني لا
يريد يفتح لا باب ولا نافذه على المحتجين
حتى يتفاوضات ويسجلت اليها باتت السمه
الابرز فيها هي المقاربه الامنيه هل يعتمد
النظام على هذه المقاربه لانعدام الخيارات
لديه ام لقناعه راسخه بان هذا هو اا
الطريقه او ان هذه الطريقه الان جعل
لكبحجم حديث تدهورت
الانظمه المؤدلجه هذا تصرف لا يمكن لها ان
تجزء الكتله الايديولوجيه المتراصه
المرتبطه ببعضها البعض عندما همم شاهدنا
ذلك حصل في الاتحاد السوفيتي انهار خيانه
الاتحاد السوفيتي بكل قوه وتحول الى دول
وهمم انتهت الحقبه الشوفيتيه لان الفكر
المارشي الذي كان يحكم
النظام لن يقبل باي تحديث وتغيير لانه
الايدلوجيه متكامله الاسلام السياسي لا
يختلف كثيرا عن عن
الانظمه
الاسلام السياسي ايضا لديه نظريه متكامله
للحكم لذا اي تغيير في اي جزيئات في
جزيئات هذه هذه الفكره قد تؤدي الى
انهياره لذا النظام يعتبر اي تراجع سيؤدي
الى انهياره لن يخطوا اي خطوه بهذا
الاتجاه ويستمر كما تفضلت بالحل الامني في
مواجهه الاحتجاجات وبعد قد تمر ذكرى
الثالثه لمقتل قاسم سليماني وهي ايضا تاتي
مع تحديات همم غير مسبوقي وجها النظام نظر
هذه الاحتجاجات هل من الممكن ان نصف هذه
الاحتجاجات اذن او هذه التحديات بصوره
عامه
بالتحديات الوجوديه
بلا شك بلا شك الان لو كانت الاحتجاجات
لفتره قصيره وتنتهي لو كانت الاحتجاجات
مطلبيه ترتبط بقضايا مطلبيه وتنتهي كان
يمكن ان نعتبرها لا تشكل تحديا حقيقيا
للنظام وليست مظاهرات بالنسبه لنظام مساله
وجود وعدم وجود ولكن الان بما ان مستوى
الشعارات الشعارات ارتقت الى اعلى
المستويات الممكنه لا للمرشد لا نريد
الملالي
وارحلوا وشعارات من هذا القبيل هذا اكبر
دليل بان النظام يشعر بانه قد يصل الى
حافه الهاويه لدى
يفرز على الذين تابعين له ان يكونوا جادين
ومتشددين في مواجهه المحتاجين لان المعركه
اصبح معركه وجود بالنسبه لهم
شكرا لك من دبي كنت معنا الباحث في الشان
الايراني مسعود الفقتحد سيد مسعود شكرا لك
وفيها بعد الفاصل في تونس القبض على قيادي
السابق في حركه النهضه بتهمه تبييض اموال
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اكدت وزاره
الداخليه التونسيه
القات القبض على قياده وعضو يسابق لمكتب
تنفيذي لحزب سياسي بتهمه تبييض اموال ذلك
في اشاره الى حركه النهضه واوضحت الداخليه
التونسيه في بعين الله عن الاحتجاز جاء
بناء على تهاميض اموال فقط عشرات
المليارات وذلك باعتماد هندسه ماليه
التمويه على تدفقات الماليه المشبوهه على
حسابات البنكيه التي وقعت تجميدها باذن
قضائيين وفق ما افاده البيان
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها
الجويه اسقطت 13 طائره مسيره روسيه فجر
اليوم
انفجارات في سماء العاصمه وقال رئيس
بلديتها
ان نظام الدفاع الجوي يعمل للدفاع عن
المدينه
[موسيقى]
تحتيه حيويه في خرسون وانا المدينه
المجاوره تركت بدون كهرباء
مشاهدين الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك سيد
محمد معنا في هذه النشره وكيف استفاق
الاوكرانيون في هذا اليوم من العام الجديد
صباح العام الجديد جاء بعد ليله قاسيه من
حيث دوله الانذار بعد حوالي يعني 20 دقيقه
من كلمه الرئيس عند الساعه الثانيه عشر
دوله سفرات الانذار وبدات الهجوم على بعض
المدن الاوكرانيه
بمسيرات اطلقت من البحر الاسود والمسيرات
اطلقت من بيلاروسيا اكثر من 33 هدف تم
اسرته في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
بينها صاروخين مجنحين تم اسقاطهم ويعني
سقط حطام هذه الصواريخ على منازل في منطقه
هلاستريون وفي
ايضا يعني همم يعني كم لا حوالي دقيقه خمس
دقائق من الان اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انه يعني في منذ الساعه 12:00
حتى يعني ساعات الصباح ساعات صباح الاولى
45 مسيره ايرانيه الصنع همم اطلقتها قوات
الروسيه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه في جنوب اوكرانيا وفي
همم وفي شرق وشمالي اوكرانيا خاصه ان
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف كانت يعني همم
صنعت يعني اصوات الانفجارات منذ الساعه
الواحده حتى الساعه الرابعه صباحا كان
هناك اصوات انفجارات في سماء العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف حيث ان الدفاعات الجويه
استطاع يعني اقامت بجرب الاهداف الجويه من
صواريخ ومسيرات اطلقت على العاصمه همم
اوكراني ايضا انها ردت على هذه الضربات
الروسيه بهجمات نفذ على لوجان
بحسب الانفصاليين هناك هل صدرت اي تصريحات
رسميه اوكرانيه حول ذلك
يعني دقيقه البيان الصباحي لهيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه تحدث ان الجيش الاوكراني قام
بقصف مصادر النيران التي تطلق النار
باتجاه المدن الاوكرانيه في مكعتي لوغانس
ودونيس وايضا في جنوب اوكرانيا في خرسون
عفوا الجيش الاوكراني اكد انه قصف
مستودعات اسلحه ومراكز تجمع للقوات
الروسيه في ضواحي مدينه في منطقه ما ادى
الى مقتل عدد من الجنود الروس ويصابه اكثر
من 45 جندي روسي كانوا متواجدين داخل
قاعده عسكريه هذه القاعده العسكريه في مكه
تعتبر قياده العمليات العسكريه التي تقوم
بالهجوم على منطقه
ايضا في مقاطعه لوكاس الجيش الاوكراني
يستمر بتقدمه باتجاه مدينه الكريمينيا
وبالامس تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني ان مدينه
كريميه
ستكون يعني خلال ايام قليله بيد القوات
الاوكرانيه حيث يرشد الجيش الاوكراني هجوم
عنيف على تلك المنطقه يدفع القوات الروسيه
ويمكن قول ان الحشد العسكري الاوكراني في
تلك المنطقه يركز على قطع خطوط الامداد
العسكريه للجيش الروسي الاتيه من منطقه
باتجاه مقاطعه لوغانسكو ايضا الجيش
الاوكراني بدا بنشر بطاريه يعني منظومات
هما في منطقه لوكاس استعدادا للهجوم
الكبير على تلك المدن يعني يبدو محمد ان
ليله راس السنه لم تخفف ابدا من عنف هذه
المواجهات في كل هذه المناطق
يعني كان هناك الصعيد يمكن الكون ليله راس
السنه خاصه بعد الضربات الروسيه ولكن يعني
ااه ااه وهو سكر مجلس الامن القومي
والدفاع الاوكراني وجه رساله يعني خلال
تصريح له او تغريد على تويتر قال ان همم
يعني الصواريخ الاوكرانيه ستكون في موسكو
قريبا يعني هناك تهديد همم ويتجول في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انه ربما سيكون في المرحله
المقبله ان اوكرانيا ستستطيع تنفيذ عمليات
داخل العاصمه الروسيه سننتفق بهذا الشكر
لك من كي- كنت معنا الصحفي محمد البابا
شكرا شكرا
مراسل العربيه مشاهدينا يتحدث حسب الخبر
العاجل بالمصدر العرب طيب اذا نلتقي
المشاهدين الى مراسل العربيه بموقع فندق
طاله القصف يطلعنا على التفاصيل
في اقل من 48 ساعه الى غارات جديده طال
القصف هذه المره مباني سكنيه في منطقه
فيتشرزي لما صاروخ روسي احد الفنادق في
وسط العاصمه حيث قتل شخص جراء شظيه كما
طال القصفه منطقه نتيجه قضايا سقطت لتصيبه
بعض المباني وتخلف عدد من المصابين الذين
ننقلوا الى المشافي لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه
بلغ عدد الضحايا اثنا عشر مصابا بينهم
مواطن في حاله حرجه بحسب السلطات الدمار
هنا حيث واقف طال جميع المباني في المحيط
تحطمت النوافذ الزجاجيه وخلعت الابواب
رئيسي مكتب ديوان الرئيس الاوكراني علق
على الهجوم ووصفه من هجوم الارهابي وقال
ان الرؤوس تعمدوا استهداف مناطق ماهوله
بالسكان في عطله يا اعياد الميلاد وراس
السنه لارهاب الاوكرانيين وكسر عزيمتهم
وقد كانت الحكومه في حاله تاهب متوقعه هذا
الهجوم كما قال الرئيس الاوكراني زين يسك
ان الروس لن يفوتوا مثل هذه المناسبه دون
محاوله ارهاب المواطنين وتنفيذ ضربات
جديده ويذكر ان السلطات الغد جميع مظاهر
الاحتفالات في كيدز وجميع المدن
الاوكرانيه وشددت على الالتزام بحظر
التجوالي مما يجبر الاوكرانيين على
استقبال العام الجديد في بيوتهم لقناتيه
العربيه والحدث حذيفه عادل كيف
انا اتقبل ما يحدث وانا افهم ذلك لا اريد
المخاطره بحياتي لقضاء هذا اليوم بالطريقه
التي كانت عليها من قبل حيث تغيرت حياتنا
وعلينا التكييف
يحاولون افساد العام الجديد كنا نتوقع ذلك
لسنا مستئين
اود حقا ان اقضيها مع اصدقائي المقربين
لذا فهذه هي الخطط الان انا بدي اطلع حقا
الى ان تنتهي الغاره الجويه قريبا ويمكنني
الذهاب والالتقاء
اكد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوز البواري المواصله الدعم
لاوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا خلال العام
الجديد وقال بوليف تغريد على تويتر
الاتحاد مصمم على مواصله الوقوف الى جانب
اوكرانيا في عام 2030 اوبل 2023 واتهم
المسؤول الاوروبي روسيا بالتخلي عن
التزاماتها بحقوق الانسان اساسيه من خلال
مهاجمه اوكرانيا والامن العالمي وفقا
تعبير هذا هو افرجت كل من روسيا واوكرانيا
عن اكثر من 200 جندي اسير في صفقه لتبادل
الاسرى وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
اوكرانيا اطلقت صراحه 82 جنديا روسيا
بينما اعلى رئيس الاركان الاوكراني عن
تسليم روسيا ل 100 و40 جنديا اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
يعقد لقاء بين وزراء خارجيه تركيا وسوريا
وروسيا في النصف الثاني من يناير الحالي
وزير خارج التركي مراد
الكامل من شمال سوريا
قرب حدودها بينما تسعى روسيا الى تصفيه
حليف للولايات المتحده في سوريا اما
النظام السوري في يريد السيطره على
الاراضي وخصوصا الثروات النفطيه من
الاكراد في شمال شرقي البلاد اقتراب
الاتفاق الثلاثي يضع الاكراد الذي لا
تصدقوا بشراسه خلال سنوات النزاع السوري
لتنظيم داعش
خيارات احلها مره ففي حال رفض الاكراد
تلبيه مطلب انقره المتجدد بالانسحاب
لمسافه 30 كم عن الحدود فان التقارب
الثلاثيه ذلك سيشكل محركا لحرب تركيا هناك
ولرئيس التركي ما يشجع على ذلك
فانتصاره في حال خاض حرب هنا قد يقوي من
موقفه قبيله موعد الانتخابات التركيه
يونيو المقبل وسط دعوات الاوروبيه لتركيا
بضروره التفريق بين حزب العمال الكردستاني
والاكراد
اهداف مختلفه الوطن كل واحد تاتي تفاهمات
الدول الثلاث مفجره قلقا لدى الاكراد خشيه
التضحيه بهم وان يدفعوا الثمن التقارب
والتصالح حرب جديده على الارض
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
نعم هو اخر تصريح هو تصريح وزير الخارجيه
مولود شاويش اوغلو احمد يوم امس في
البرازيل عندما سئل عن هذا الموضوع قال
انه في خلال اتصالهم بنظره الروسي سيرجي
لافروف ساله الوزير الروسي متى سيكون
الاجتماع القادم او الاجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه قال الوزير رد الوزير التركي بان
الاجتماع عندما تكون الظروف مناسبه وخطوات
ملموسه ويمكن ان يكون قريبا جدا
اقترح الوزير الروسي ان يكون النصف الثاني
من يناير ووافق الوزير التركي بالتالي من
المنتظر ان يكون في النصف الثاني من يناير
لكن حتى الان التوقيت الدقيق وموعد حتى
ال- همم او مكان اللقاء حتى الان غير
معروف ربما في موسكو وربما في دوله ثالثه
كما قال همم الوزير التركي وزير الخارجيه
التركي قال هناك عده خيارات مطروحه لكن
حتى الان لم يتم تحديد الموعد الدقيق ولا
حتى ما كان عقاد الاجتماع هل توضحت
معلومات او تسريبات عن ابرز الخلافات التي
اوقفت وسطناقش ايضا في الاجتماع المقبل
بين تركيا وسوريا بواسطه الروسيه
نعم لا شك اليوم ان هناك مواضيع همم
مشتركه يمكن ان يتوصل الجانبان الى نقاط
تفاهم ولو بنسبه معقوله فيها لاسيه ونتحدث
عن موضوع حزب العمال الكردستاني والمسلحين
الاكراد المسؤولون الاتراك صرحوا خلال
الايام الماضيه ان كان وزير الخارجيه او
وزير الدفاع بان هناك تفاهم او ارضيه همم
ارضيه التفاهم ما بين الجانب همم او
النظام السوري وانقر حول موضوع التهديد
المسلحين الاكراد وهنا تحدث عن وحدات
الحمايه الكرديه التي تصنفها انقره فرع من
همم او كفرها لحزب العمال الكردستاني في
سوريا همم هناك تفاهم او هناك رؤيه مشتركه
ما بين دمشق وانقره بان المسلحين الاكراد
يشكلون تهديدا على همم الامن القومي
لتركيا وعلى حتى على الامن في دمشق او حتى
دمشق لذلك همم ربما كان هناك مقترح روسي
بايجاد ارضيه مشتركه لربما في مستقبل في
المستقبل عسكريه مشتركه همم بين الجانبين
ضد القوات الكرديه لكن هذا الموضوع ايضا
هنا نتحدث ان الولايات المتحده تدعم
المسلحين الاكراد لذلك هذا الموضوع شائك
نوعا الملفات الاخرى المطروحه طبعا مستقبل
القوات التركيه في سوريا صحيح ان الجانب
التركي قال انه سينسحب من المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها لكنه اشترت عوده الاستقرار
والامور الى طبيعته وهذه همم كلمه او جمله
عامه يعني او ربما تتطلب مسار طويل جدا
حتى تتحقق من خلال هذه المباحثات ومن خلال
ما همم نلمسه من مباحثاتها تريد همم تطوير
اتفاقيه اضنه من خمسه كيلو مترات داخل
الحدود السوريه ان يكون لها حق التدخل في
لعمر خمسه كيلومترات الى 30 كلم وبالتالي
همم تريد ان تكون وجودها او تصبغ على
وجودها الشرعيه وفق اتفاق مع النظام
نعم بالاساس اتفاقيه اضنه التي وقعت عام
1998 كانت تمنح انقره امكانيه التدخل بعمق
خمسه كيلومترات جنوب الحدود او في داخل
الحدود السوريه في حال كان هناك تهديد جدي
على امنها القومي وبالتالي في حاله تم
تطوير هذه الاتفاقيه او تعديلها اا طبعا
يحق لها ضمن الاتفاقيه اذا اذا وافق طبعا
النظام السوري على تطوير هذه اتفاق يحق
لها ان همم تدخل او تتوغل بعمق 30 كلم لكن
حتى الان هذا الموضوع السابق اوانه تركي
لم يتم التصريح عنه على نيه لكن همم
التسريبات التي رشحت كانت تؤكد ان الاتراك
طرح هذه
المباحثات لكن اذا ايضا هل يلقى هذا
التقارب مع سوريا قبولا من كافه الاطراف
السياسيه في البلاد خاصه المعارضه ام ان
هناك اصوات رافضه لهذه الخطوه
لا شك ان نتحدث عن المعارضه التركيه هي
اول من طرح فكره اعاده العلاقات مع النظام
وتحديدا منذ عام 2013 كان هناك مطلب من
المعارضه الرئيسيه في تركيا ونتحدث عن حزب
الشعب الجمهوري لكن اليوم مع اقتراب
الانتخابات لا شك ان هذه هي سياسه
المعارضه هي التي تعهدت بانها ستعيد فتح
همم السفاره التركيه في دمشق واعاده
العلاقات مع النظام واعاده اللاجئين كانت
هي يعني كانت تتمنى المعارضه ان تبادل هي
بهذه الخطوه وان تكون الحضوه وبالتالي همم
تسحب الورقه هذه الورقه من الرئيس التركي
لكن على ما يبدو ان الرئيس التركي ولي
اهداف انتخابيه صرع من هذه العمليه وبادر
هو بهذه الخطوه حتى يصل الرساله للشارع
التركي بانه قادر على حل مشكله اللاجئين
وهي مشكله وايضا المزاج الشعبي العام في
تركيا لا يفضل وجود اللاجئين ويحبب عوده
اللاجئين همم السرعه القصوى لذلك هذه
الورقه اراد حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس
اردوغان سحب هذه الورقه من يد عرض وان
يبادر هو بهذه الخطوه ربما هناك همم
كثيرون كثيرون يرون ان التطبيع العلاقات
بشكل كامل وحل كل المشاكل مع نظام مسار
طويل جدا ويحتاج ايضا الى ليس فقط مشاركه
روسيا وساطه روسيه يحتاج الى الامم
المتحده والولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي وتطبيق القرار 22 54 لكن الاتراك
يحاولون على الاقل الان ولو بشكل اعلامي
همم عقد لقاءات مع المسؤولين في النظام
السوري صار رساله لشارع التركي بانهم
جديون في حل هذه المشكله
شكرا لك من اسطنبول كنت معنا مراسل
العربيه
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
طالب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان القاده السياسيين بعدم
تضيع فرصه توحيد الصف السوداني التي وصفها
بالتاريخيه مشيراني الان الاخصاء وفرض
الوصايه من فئه محدده سيضيعاني امنا ووحده
البلاد
والسياسيين من ان الفرصه التاريخيه لتوحيد
الصف
وحده وبناء الدوله السودانيه حصل عليها
الشعب السوداني بعد تضحيات جسيمه
من الوقت ينتظر تكرارها مره اخرى
وتقديم دور الاخرين وعدم الاستماع الى
مطالبهم وفرض الوصايا عليهم محدده من
قطاعات الشعب صبيه هذه الفرصه
امن بلدنا في خطر كبير
ده شاطره مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
قريبا قرار حاسم بشان عوده الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الى فيسبوك
نقطه تفتيشن للشرطه امام مطار العسكري وسط
التبول
رئيس البرلماني الايراني
في الوقت المناسب
اوكرانيا تقول ان روسيا شنت سبعين هجوما
براجمات الصواريخ ودفاعاتها تسقط 13 مسيره
روسيه
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يامر بتعزيز تاره
سنته النوويه هو رئيس وزاره الجنوبيه
يتعاهد بالرد
اهلا بكم
اذا كان ستسمح لرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بالعوده الى الفيسبوك
نهائيا
من السياسه العامه وفرق الاتصالات وسياسه
المحتوى في سياق اخر مشاهدينا قال الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ان رغباته
للعام الجديده تشمل تسويه الحرب في
اوكرانيا على وجه السرعه منتقدا سياسه
اداره امريكيه الحاليه ومعتبرا اياه هات
وردت في حرب ادت الى اذان كثير الى اذى
كثير من الناس والبلدان
تحدث الان وتؤذي كثيرا حقا اعاني قتل
الكثير من الناس فيتضر بالكثير من البلدان
ناموا ان يتم تقويم ذلك بسرعه كبيره مع
اوكرانيا وروسيا يجب ان احصل ذلك يجب ان
تكون لدينا حدود قويه
ظهر زعم كوريا في عرض لراجمات الصواريخ
جديده خارج مبنى اللجنه المركزيه لحزب
العمال الحاكم وقال لك ان رجومات الصواريخ
الجديده تجعل كوريا الجنوبيه باسرها في
نطاق الاستهداف مشيرا الى انها قادره على
حمل رؤوس نوويه تكتيكيه جاء عرض الاسلحه
الجديده بعد يوم من اطلاق صواريخ وفي
نهايه اجتماع الحزب العمال الحاكم
صنع المزيد من الاسلحه النوويه في
المقابله رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
مستمره في استفزازاتها الصاروخيه والنوويه
وشدد رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه على ضروره ان
يكون الجيش مستعيدا لرد على استفزازات
كوريا الشماليه بشكل الانتقاميا وواضح
بحسب تعبيره
كوريا الشماليه تنهي لعام 2022
باطلاق تجارب على ثلاثه صواريخ باليسيه
وهو عدد كبير لاطلاق صواريخ في يوم واحد
استعراض للاسلحه مع تصاعد التوتر في شبه
جزيره الكوريه بعدما اتهمت سول جارتها
الشماليه بتسير خمسه طائرات مسيره عبر
الحدود للمره الاولى منذ خمس سنوات وردت
بارسال طائرات مسيره نحو الشمال
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
كوريا الشماليه بعواقب وخيمه
شبكه الدفاع الجوي لبلاده مع التعهدي
بالتعامل الصارم مع استفزازات في كوريا
الشماليه كما وصفت هيئه الاركان المشتركه
عمليات الاطلاق بانها استفزاز خطير يقود
السلامه الدولي مع تشديد سول بمراقبته
تحركات كوريا الشماليه عن قرب بالتنسيق مع
الولايات المتحده قوه نوويه كما يصفها
رئيسها كيم جونغ اون فبيونجيان اختبرت هذا
العام اكثر من 70 صاروخا شملت اطلاق
صواريخ بالسيه عابره للقارات تحضروا
عقوبات الامم المتحده اختباراتها
ومهما يكون من امر فان التوترات في شبه
جزيره الكوريه واليابان سيرحل للعام
الجديد لتصعيد غير مسبوق قد يفتح ازمه
جديده تضاف الى ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
قال مدير مكتب الشؤون الخارجيه لحزب
الشيوعي الصيني ونكي انه يجب على بكين
مباشره
في مواجهه التحديات مؤكدا انه يتعين على
الطرفين رسم طريق التوافق والاحترام
معلومات من بكيني
في الصين
حيث طلب استراليا
اليها من الصين اعتبارا من الخامس
قبل السفر الى كندا التي اكدت على سلبيه
نتائج الاختبارات قبل الدخول اليها كما
قررت الولايات المتحده الى جانب اليابان
ودول الاوروبي عده فرض ضوابطها على
المسافرين الوافدين من الصين في ظل
اجراءات الاحتياطيه اعتبرها رئيس منظمه
الصحه العالميه مفهومه
بعوده حركه السفر بين بلدينا هذا امر جيد
لنا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه والاعشرات او
مئات الالاف من الاشخاص الذين انفصلوا عن
عائلتهم واصدقائهم لكن منظمه الصحه
العالميه اوضحت ان هناك نقصا في المعلومات
حول الوضع في الصين وان الوضع يتطور بصوره
سريعه لذلك وصفت الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
مجموعه من الدول في اسيا وامريكا الشماليه
واوروبا بانها اجراءات مفهومه وكم الدول
الاخرى اود ان اؤكد ان هذه الاجراءات التي
اتخذناها مؤقته وتعاكس حاله نقص المعلومات
في الوقت الحالي حول وضع كوفي في الصين
ولو مشاهدينا
اقتصاد مع الزمالك
شكرا لاحمد مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من
جديد اليوم سوق الاسهم السعوديه السوق
العامله اليوم تسجل المكاسب في اولى جلسات
العام الجديد ولكن هذا كان اداء في العام
الماضي سجل التراجع بسبعه بالمئه بعد
ارتفاعات ب 30 بالمئه في العام 2021 دبي
في العام الماضي كانت مرتفعه ابو ظبي مسقط
البحرين ايضا على ارتفاع من ناحيه اخرى
سوق القطريه كانت الاسواداء بين اسواق
الخليج وسجل تراجعات ثانويه اكيد هذا
العام كان عام فيه تحديات كبيره لاسواق
الاسهم وحتى اسواق السندات اسوا عام عام
2022 كان اسوا عاملي اسواق الاسهم
العالميه منذ الازمه الماليه العالميه عام
2008 عم نتحدث عن 14 مليون دولار تمحي من
الاسواق العالميه تحدي الاساسي كان همم
بدا مع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وبعد
تفاقم مشكله التضخم وبالتالي البنوك
المركزيه برفع سريع لاسعار الفائده اا
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي رفع الفائده العام
الماضي ب 400 نقطه اساس البنك المركزي
الاوروبي رفعها ب 250 نقطه اساس ولحقت به
البنوك المركزيه الخليجيه لاحقه
بالاحتياطي الفيدرالي بالطبع لانه عملاتها
مرتبطه بالدولار لذلك ايضا يعني هذه
التراجعات كنا نراها على سوق الاسهم
السعوديه امر طبيعي في ظل خسائر حاده سجلت
باسواق الاسهم العالميه الامريكيه تحديدا
احد الناس ذات 33% خسائر كانت المشكله
الاكبر باسهم التكنولوجيا اللي بتتاثر
بشكل اكبر بارتفاعات اسعار الفائده الا ان
اسهم مثل جوجل مايكروسوفت مثل جوجل متى
همم
اكثر من 60% في العام الماضي جوجل امازون
متراجع بين 40 الى 50% ولكن لاحظوا اسهم
القيمه
الفاليوس كان فيها مراجعات الاقل في ظل
معكوسه بتراجع على مؤشر الداون جونز اللي
بيحمل هذه الاسهم بحدود تسعه بالمئه كان
الاقل خساره بين اسواق
الاسهم الامريكيه الاساسيه واداء الاسواق
الاسيويه ايضا في العام الماضي كان سيء
جدا مشاهدينا ان نعود معكم في برنامج
الاسواق العربيه بعد قليل لتحديث ارقام
سوق الاسهم السعوديه المرتفعه اليوم اما
الان نعود الى احمد لمتابعه نشاط الاخبار
شكرا لارا مشاهدينا المؤشر العام لبارو
متر السياحه المصريه هو عنوان دراسه قام
بها مجلس الوزراء ظهرت نظره تفاؤليه فيما
يخص اداء قطاع السياحه والاقتصاد المصري
خبراء سياحه وضعوا بعض التوصيات لتعظيم
بينما يرى جيل الشباب ان الامر يحتاج ايضا
لافكار خارج الصندوق
احمد القاضي تمسك بقطاع السياحه الذي عمل
به على مدار 20 عاما وبدا يعمل من المنزل
هو وزملائه في الشركه الامر الذي استمر
حتى مع عوده تدفق السائحين الى مصر وانت
عايش القطاع
له يقدر قيمه تجارب الدول اخرى في ضبط
ايقاع القطاع السياحي والترويجي للسياحه
من خلال المنصات الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
هتساعد جدا المركب في مصر او هتساعد
برودكت ان هو يطلع لنور في مصر وفي نفس
الوقت مصر ولادي في فتره اللي جايه دي
وقاعده جدا ان هي تقدر تاخذ ماركه شركه
كويس من سحره الخارجيه ال ال الاجنبيه
دراسه حكوميه تحمل اسم المؤشر العام لبرو
متر السياحه اظهرت تفاؤل مجتمع الاعمال
بمستقبل قطاع السياحه في مصر هذا التفاعل
تعاكسه نسب اشتغالات مرتفعه في معظم
الفنادق والمقاصد المصريه خاصه في هذا
الوقت من العام ولكن للوصول للمستهدف 30
مليون سائح سنويا خلال هذا العقد يرى
خبراء السياحه انه يتعين على الحكومه
المصريه ان تتخذ عدد من الاجراءات الداعمه
على القطاع
السياحه دينا خطاب تروج للسياحه من والى
مصر عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولها
متابعون كثير وهي ايضا تعمل من خلال شركه
سياحه مرخصه تمتلكها وترى ان هناك الكثير
الذي يمكن للقطاع من خلال شباب العاملين
الذين يفكرون خارج الصندوق بحسب قوله»
قطع سياحه متفائلين جدا يعني مثلا شركات
السياحه دلوقتي ترخيص شركات سياحه مقفول
الناس بتبقى قاعده عندنا هنا جوه مصر
وبتعرف تجيب من جميع دول العالم وتقول
زوروا مصر همم فندي امكانيه للناس دي ان
هي تشتغل وتفتح نفتح لهم بس الرخصه همم
ونخليهم يشتغلوا بشكل اوضح فيه فكر عظيم
هنا همم يعني مدفون فعلا محتاج بس مساعده
او دعم الدراسه الحكوميه تستعرضه توصيات
الخبراء ومنها تبسيط واجراءات تاسيس
المشروعات السياحيه وتخفيض الرسوم عليها
وتدريب العاملين بالقطاعه بالاضافه الى
رفع الوعي السياحي واحكام الرقابه لحسن
التعامل مع السائح والترويجي للمقصد
السياحي المصري تامر نصره العربيه القاهره
الارز الحساوي موروث شعب تتوارث الاجيال
زراعته في مدينه الاحساء السعوديه على مدى
اكثر من 1900 عام بتفاصيل اكثر تشاهد
الارز
[موسيقى]
ايضا الصين نفسها اخذت البدور جربته
بالصين مانجا تهنيئا مو نقول للاحصائيين
لكل مواطن سعودي يفتخر ان هذا المنتج
جرب في دول العالم ولا نجح الا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
وفي الختام مشاهدينا باقي ان نذكر
بالعناوين
استهدف نقطه التفتيش الى الشرطه امام مطار
العسكريه
رئيس البرلماني الايراني يقر بحاجه نظام
الحكم لاصلاحات واتخاذ القرارات في الوقت
المناسب
اوكرانيا تقول ان روسيا جنه 70 هجوما
براجمات الصواريخ ودفاعتها تسقط 13 مسيره
روسيه
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يامر بتعزيز ترسانته
النوويه هو رئيس وزاره الجنوبيه يتعهدوا
بالرد
نهايه وادي الساعه الاخباريه
[موسيقى]